unkraut namens risiko im eigenen leben
sprechen zu lassen
das leben in einer blase absoluter
sicherheit in einem sorgen und
risikofreien paradies es ist undenkbar
macht keinen sinn
denn
das geheimnis um den größten genuss vom
dasein zu amten heißt gefährlich leben
baut eure städte an den vesuv
schickt eure schiffe in unerforschte
meere
dazu hat einst friedrich nietzsche
aufgerufen
und damit die britische autorin pauli
moreland bei ihrer arbeit an einem buch
über risiken nachhaltig inspiriert
ich wollte herausfinden wie es für die
menschen ist gefährlich zu leben mit
ausrufezeichen und den hängen des vesuvs
und sie hat sich aufgemacht nach neapel
und weiter rund um die welt und menschen
porträtiert die mit risiken leben und
gelernt haben diese weise und
bereichernd in ihren alltag zu
integrieren indem sie sie mit ihren
werten verbinden
die spitzen tänzerin die für die
schönheit der kunst ihre gesundheit
riskiert der new yorker risikomanager
der einstürzende häuser verzeichnet die
blinde ski rennfahrerin kinder beim
spiel wie sie lernen das wagnis
auszuloten oder eben menschen am vesuv
für die das risiko vulkan die werte
heimat und familie nicht zu überwinden
vermag
und für die menschen die ich interviewte
war das risiko einer lebenskraft eine
welt von möglichkeiten
manchmal müssen wir auf das risiko zu
gehen nicht vor ihm wegrennen
wir sind eine von sicherheit besessene
udn belastbare gesellschaft geworden
sagt moment eine gesellschaft die von
ansteckenden kollektiven ängsten
durchdrungen ist
säkularisierung und individualisierung
haben uns zu den alleinverantwortlichen
autoren unseres lebens gemacht
das hat ein gefühl kreiert das risiko
nicht mehr delegieren können zu gott zu
einer vorsehung oder einer sozialen
ordnung über die wir keine kontrolle
haben daraus entsteht diese
beunruhigende vorstellung
es ist in unserer hand jetzt wir machen
besser keinen fehler
fehler machen wagnisse eingehen aber
sind elementar für einsicht und
fortschritt alles andere heißt
stillstand und je sicherer wir sind umso
sicherer wollen wir werden
dieser ewige kreislauf der
risikominimierung verschließt irgendwann
den zugang zu unseren besten idee
auf diese ideen zu kommen erfordert von
uns aus unserer komfortzonen
herauszutreten
moment selber lebt mit ihrer familie in
wales in einer ziemlich risikoarmen
komfortzone doch sagt sie es gibt in
jedem alltag abenteuer in denen der
risikofreudige muskel trainiert werden
kann es gibt kleine partikel von
gefahren in so vielem was wir tun wir
steigen ins auto wir steigen die treppen
rauf und runter wir kaufen ein haus
werden eltern wir sagen unsere meinung
du erzählst du jemandem zum ersten mal
dass du ihn liebst
ein riesiges risiko es ist kein risiko
von leib und leben aber es ist ein
riesiges persönliches risiko
instinktiv und intuitiv tun wir es
täglich riskieren heißt leben und wir
sollten anfangen zu feiern dass wir es
tun
die menschliche erfahrung ist ein extrem
lanciertes kompliziertes wunderbares
manchmal schrecklich tragisch und
traurig manchmal wunderschönes komplexes
gebilde
und dazu schauen was wir daraus lernen
können das ist etwas das das ganze leben
lang anhält
ich mache mir große sorgen über jedes
kleinste risiko das ich angehen aber ich
gehe so weiterhin ein und das ist das
was ich gelernt habe mit dem buch es ist
okay sich unwohl zu fühlen deswegen
dieses gefühl des unbehagens ist gut
denn es zahlt sich aus und die einzig
wirkliche gefahr im leben ist jene nicht
genug riskiert zu haben oder um es mit
den worten von anais nin zu sagen das
leben schrumpft oder dehnt sich aus
proportional zum eigenen mut